en parler nous recevons adlène mohammedi
docteur en géographie politique
spécialiste de la politique arabe de la
russie adlène meddi bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation directe
sur air france
on le disait donc un la ligue arabe
vient de rejeter un ce plan américain
les propos de mahmoud abbas qui diront
pro totalement les liens à la fois avec
israël et washington
au fond est-ce qu'on s'y attendait alors
pas nécessairement c'est plutôt une
position assez courageuse de la part de
l'autorité palestinienne de demain sur
la base ce n'était pas forcément
prévisible puisque la pl l'autorité
palestinienne a ces dernières années
fait preuve d'une certaine prudence à
l'égard des américains
donc oui c'est plutôt courageuse qui ce
qui était peut être un peu moins
prévisible c'est la réaction d'un giga
rap qui quand même dominé par pas relax
ryad abou dhabi plutôt bienveillants à
l'égard de deux de trump et de kouchner
et doivent être prises et son plan et de
son plan de paix entre guillemets donc
oui pour le cool je pense que la ligue
arabe l'avait pas le choix c'est à dire
qu'il y avait il à bhl après la pression
palestinienne il faut dire aussi que la
question palestine et l'une des raisons
d'être de la ligue arabe historiquement
donc la pression palestinienne la
pression des populations arabes ont fait
que la ligue arabe n'avait pas d'autre
choix que de peu de de renoncer à ce
plan alors le président turc a rich ayez
per à doan a accusé il ya quelques jours
certains paysages justement de trahir
cette cause palestinienne à qui fait-il
référence
il fait référence essentiellement à laax
ryad
abou dhabi aux saoudiens et aux émirati
pour une raison assez simple on a déjà
accompli nette entre la turquie et sa
taxe ce conflit se manifeste notamment
sur le théâtre libyen mais aussi parce
que c'est vrai c'est à dire parce que
rien d abu dhabi sont les partenaires
arabes les plus proches de washington et
ont plutôt salué la proposition
l'initiative de donald trump
ce qui a choqué une partie du monde
arabe ce qui était très prévisible mais
ce qu'il ya néanmoins choqué le monde
arabe est en vigueur que par ailleurs la
turquie apparaît comme le grand parrain
régional de l'islam politique et veut je
pense que la turquie veut faire de la
cause palestinienne cause musulmane
elle insiste beaucoup d'ailleurs sur le
statut de jérusalem et ça porte un
risque parce que la cause palestinienne
est tout sauf une cause musulmane selon
klaus territoriales qui concerne
évidemment beaucoup de chrétiens
donc oui on a un risque mais ce risque
là se pose précisément parce que les
pays arabes de la région ont fait preuve
d'une dune plus illimité assez
déconcertante mais au fond mahmoud abbas
est peut-être moins esseulé qu'il
n'aurait pu être finalement aujourd'hui
après sept
ce rejet de la ligue arabe de ce plan
américain oui c'est vrai mais je pense
que les palestiniens ont rarement été
aussi haut aussi fragilisé sur la scène
internationale ils n'ont pas de ils ne
peuvent compter sur personne aujourd'hui
ils ne peuvent compter sur personne pas
même sur la france je vous lis la
déclaration de la porte-parole du quai
d'orsay la france exprime sa conviction
que la solution de deux états en
conformité avec le droit international
et les paramètres internationalement
agréés est nécessaire à l'établissement
d'une paix juste et durable au proche
orient
du coup est ce que la palestine peut
trouver un soutien auprès de la france
et plus généralement près de l'europe
aujourd'hui absolument pas et cette
déclaration est
et déconcertante tenta bien vite on n'a
strictement rien dit quand on a des
seins invoquait le droit international
dans le vide ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt et et aucune importance non le
les palestiniens ne peuvent certainement
pas compter sur sur les européens et
j'ai envie de dire que même les
allemands
les allemands étaient un peu moins
prudent on va dire que que que la
diplomatie française mais c'est ça reste
quand même
cette prudence et 7,7 cet équilibrisme
est assez choquant parce que finalement
quand on y réfléchit un peu
donald trump en réalité c'est le
résultat de ce discours à force de
renvoyer dos à dos israéliens et
palestiniens ont fini par aboutir une
certaine situation est un monsieur trump
arrive et ne fait que l'a constaté alors
alors les médias n'aiment pas beaucoup
parce que évidemment il est grotesque et
grossier mais c'est le résultat de ce 1
de ce que vous venez de lire c'est
exercer cet équilibrisme affolant entre
le bourreau et la victime qui aboutit
finalement à une sorte de réalisme
poussé un peu loin mais vous parlez
d'équilibrisme connaît côté russie à la
clarté la fermeté de la diplomatie russe
sur d'autres dossiers internationaux
on sait aussi de l'avenir poutine
benyamin nétanyahou se sont rencontrés à
de nombreuses reprises sur ce dossier là
quelle est la position de la russie
la position russe cesse d'être clair là
précisément que quand il s'agit de
dossiers palestinien alors vous avez
parlé des rencontres entre netanyahou et
poutine la dernière a eu lieu à deux
jours si je ne m'abuse c'est d'ailleurs
le premier chef d'état que le premier
ministre israélien a voulu rencontrer
pour lui soumettre ce plan de paix et
c'est lui qu'on a l'habitude de deux
déclarations russes assez simple assez
clair assez réaliste et la première
déclaration de diplomatie russe s'était
une déclaration du vice-ministre russe
des affaires étrangères mikhaïl bogdanov
qui disait ne pas savoir ce qu'en pense
et les palestiniens
c'est quand même assez affolant de faire
semblant de ne pas savoir que les
palestiniens ne veulent pas de ce plan
donc cet attentisme russe est assez
gênant alors évidemment je pense que la
russie même si vladimir poutine ne sait
pas ne s'est toujours pas exprimée
définitivement sur le sujet à temps et
c'est vrai que je pense que la russie
n'ira jamais jusqu'à accepter ce plan
puisque la l'équilibrisme habituel à la
diplomatie russe
je ne tiens ne tiendra plus donc je
pense que la russie fera preuve de
prudence mais là encore le renvoyer
systématiquement dos-à-dos israéliens et
palestiniens en faisant comme si on
avait affaire à une sorte de conflit et
équilibrée entre deux acteurs ça produit
ça en fait ça produit un plan qui finit
par tout donner ou à celui qui a gagné
et tout prendra ou plus aux plus faibles
merci beaucoup elle donne mohammedi
d'avoir partagé votre analyse sur notre
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en géographie politique
spécialiste de la politique arabe de la
russie